welcome back do we really need giant
trucks to drive our butts to Starbucks
axios it's a uh online uh thing reports
how pickup trucks have become so
imposing over the years and apparently
this is a problem imposing a word
usually reserved for museums mansions
and the stack of kill meat books in the
remainders section
it's probably unnecessary
but that's why I like it as axios points
out truck sales are through the roof as
people embrace the big truck lifestyle
pick up pickups bring in record profits
for automakers but safety Advocates are
worried their massive size weight in
blind spots render them unsafe which is
the same thing they said about the
Statue of Liberty
thank you
I'm the real hero
actually they didn't say that at all but
it sounded good
axios implies the bigger crime is that
that most don't even use their big
trucks to haul anything oh so now you're
only allowed to drive a truck if you're
loading cement what's next I can only
use my submarine to hunt mermaids
yeah
critics also complain that since trucks
are so tall in front they typically hit
pedestrians in the Torso or a head
whereas cars with lower hoods hit
pedestrians in the legs where they
deserve it
they also whine that people like their
big trucks despite the potential danger
because they're masculine rugged in
All-American and as we all know those
are three repulsive attributes that
stink of the patriarchy masculine rugged
All-American gross sounds like a Trey
Gowdy swimsuit calendar
[Applause]
but if you're wondering why trucks are
the most popular vehicles in America
observe a typical sale
foreign
can I get you in a new car today well
maybe my last car was a Prius I'm
looking for something green
uh well the way I see it you could
either buy a truck or you could be so
what do you say you take the F-150 for a
spin bring it back in about an hour okay
oh that was the test drive this truck is
awesome dog and who are these women just
some babes I'm in a truck Fest okay so
one truck coming up I'll take three
trucks three trucks one for each of my
testicles
now hop in the cab I need some help
taking down some solar panels
[Music]
[Applause]
like places like axios whether they go
out of their way to find things that
best reflect like just average Americans
to decide that they hate it obviously
the sensitive variety was cut off in
traffic by a person who looked like me
yeah fine because as an imposing an
American truck owner uh yeah I'm a giant
guy so I have a giant truck so and yeah
you know if you're gonna get hit buy a
car better off be a truck because it'll
be like that suppose you know when it
goes back to the whole thing where you
keep teasing a certain weatherman about
getting beat up by teens yes would you
rather say you got hit by a Prius or you
got run over by a truck yes you know so
you know what if it's five little
Priuses and they surround you even worse
but again this just goes back to this
thing like I said I drive a big Chevy
and uh you know I the only thing I will
give them when you see really small
people wait when you see really small
people who can barely clear the steering
wheel I know what you're saying I've
never seen you in a truck but I would
imagine you wouldn't clear the steering
wheel but
you see them and they look
kind of go
ofy but you know
as a tall person it's it's exactly what
I need so keeps me from test driving
yeah a little when they bring out the
little step ladder tray it's kind of
humbling
um people who own pickup trucks
essentially Make the World Go Round like
that axios guy has no idea that the guys
that are making sure that their food
gets to their table probably dry pickup
trucks uh well I don't make sure
people's food gets to the table but I do
drive a pickup truck for a reason that
axios did not cite
nobody has to ride with you if there's
no seat in the back so
that's why I have a big truck there's no
seat in the back nobody says hey will
you give me a ride somewhere here's the
other thing about getting hit where you
get hit it reminded me of something my
father said when I was growing up said
Trey got hit in the head where it's less
likely to do any damage
so if you're going to get hit in the
head or hitting the knee it's probably
better to get hit in the head I would
think in my case
you know that you probably might be the
first person to ever say that
and for the head not the knee Jim I
missed a good speaking of which I miss
the good old days when we were growing
up you could ride in the back seat of a
truck remember that it was it was
amazing you can hang out in the back see
the truck I was in a station wagon yeah
I was in the back of a stationary but a
truck yeah you can hang out in the back
not only that listen just for security
reasons I always wanted a truck right
and I try again a truck a couple times
my wife went for the sports car I
remember hitting a car I remember
getting an accident I was 18 with a 78
Buick LeSabre and this thing knocked the
other car about four blocks so yeah and
I got out of my car like oh my dad's
gonna kill me there wasn't a dent so
that's why I've always wanted a truck
just got and I live in Florida there's
people having Strokes just going through
a red light I want a truck
fine
that's I wanted for safety to be honest
with you trucks are fun
yeah you know cat you got a big bed in
the back you can you can play with your
dolls
[Laughter]
that is the creepiest thing yeah this
actually this axios whoever wrote it I
don't know if they know what they did
here but if you haven't noticed nobody
who owns a truck just feels kind of okay
about it as it is and if you think that
people love their trucks now this just
made them star-crossed lovers with their
trucks yes which always adds to the
Allure yeah so I think people are gonna
be like way more hardcore about their
trucks this is nobody's convinced to
give up their truck because of this now
they feel like victims exactly and by
the way you know think about this no one
in a Prius can push you out of a ditch
that's why every like it's generally the
people that pull over to help you are in
trucks and they usually have a way to
tow you out of stuff of course you might
end up dismembered in the woods but
that's
that's a risk you take in America
they'll get you out of a ditch then
they'll cut you to pieces
it's a small price to pay a small price
to make Ray
if you're nicer it's in the head
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else